when I wanted to allow is why anybody
thinks the ontological
question is interesting and needs a
solution yeah I mean the epistemological
question I think is very important and
[Music]
[Music]
you're right that's what I'm saying I'm
saying that any any inquiry about the
nature of reality which isn't an
epistemological inquiry is already off
into cloud cuckoo-land
we don't its undecidable we don't know
what we're doing we don't it's something
where you make up the rules as you go
along and I think the only thing that
disciplines a consideration of ontology
the very the very idea you know where do
we do ontology we do it in practical
areas to me one of the really
interesting things is that the term
ontology philosophers terms where it's
really playing an interesting role these
days isn't computer science because
computer science programmers are having
really interesting discussions arguments
theories about what the right ontology
is for doing certain sorts of tasks
especially medical but but there the
term ontology has a real bite and you
can see how different ways of conceiving
of the objects that your program has to
be about makes a big difference to take
a trivial example the elevator problem
you want to have a system that controls
multiple elevators turns out to be a
tricky problem if you want to optimize
you don't want to have redundancy and so
forth and so people scratch their heads
think about it in a very abstract way of
what this what's the old felt of the
elevator what does what's the manifest
image of the elevator what things does
it have to keep track of to do the job
we wanted to do and it turns out that
the best ontologies for elevators they
have to have each other in the back as
sort of agents in in the equation they
have to sort of keep track of each other
as agents they have to get sort of
game-theoretic in order to make sense of
the problem if you really want to write
and now look how how fundamental and how
sort of reductionist sicknesses this is
brute practicality you're a programmer
you have been given the job of making
and optimizing a control structure for a
bank of elevators and you come back at
the end of a long and brilliant analysis
and you say well the first thing we got
to do is we've got to endow the
elevators with a sort of game theoretic
sense of them of themselves as agents in
a multi agent world and then it goes
like abandoned now that's a really
interesting discovery about ontology in
a very constrained space and I think
that if you don't have a task like that
and you want to talk about ontology I
wanna talk about what's really real no
other elevators aren't real for the
elevator good interesting fact there's
the things that are real for us the
things that are real for Stone Age
people and living in the Amazon these
are all back to Stevens pointed the
beginning there's all kinds of reality
but I think all of them are tied in a
quite strong way to epistemology and
anybody who says then there's the
ontological as opposed to
epistemological problem I don't know
what that's about
epistemology was in the salmon for
at least in the family of de chardin
what it brought us at the end was the
positivism and with its prescription of
a large number of the questions that we
natural ists wish to answer and of
course there's a significant interaction
between epistemology and ontology that
they influence one another but in
particular because those of us around
the table particularly you have been in
the forefront of advancing a causal
theory of our epistemic States you have
a commitment at least to ontology being
on a par with epistemology and at least
many other philosophers conclude that
unless ontology is somehow prior to were
more fundamental than epistemology we
are going to find ourselves back in the
positivistic all the same and we're not
going to even be able to treat the
questions of naturalism as well that
that's a diagnosis which I am not
persuaded by at all you might be right
I think the fact that that a sort of an
over extension of the epistemological
concerns led to logical positivism
that's true but I don't think that the
corrective to that back to me evil
ontology right
I think that middle ground there is that
whenever you make an ontological claim
where you even thought that thing better
be significantly linked to your work mr.
Malla
I think that's a very fair statement and
I would be inclined to say I'm regret
that point Berg isn't here that Weinberg
would insist and Jerry has insisted all
afternoon and I would join them in
insisting that the history of science
constitutes excellent epistemological
grounds for that ontological claim the
reductionist unificationists claim but I
that he like has been defending that I
grab and that you Jerry
you do I just think that you're at least
reading the history of science yes I
find myself to the right of all you guys
because I think this is more than a
history of science claim I think that
our evidence you know again if the
Standard Model of particle physics plus
gravity is right then it just sends what
happens within its domain of
applicability and and and sort of all
the other levels yes but they're the
others but they're your own the
epistemological stand from which you
make that claim will have to do the
number of decimal places to which the
predictions are accurate which one
exceed that of any other theory yeah
just put it in the in this way I think
that my basis for making the for
believing that the standard model plus
gravity does hold in the regime which i
think is it holds is as good as for
example the histological status of the
claim that the Sun gets its energy from
nuclear fusion I think that the logic
that leads you to that conclusion and
the evidence
four is the same yep and that's not a
history of science no this is the way of
doing science five history of science I
simply mean the successive increases in
the precision and range of our
predictive confidence yes but as we said
earlier there are different ways of
looking at the history of science like
Anderson that was mentioned before a
couple of times including by Barbara you
said actually the direction of the
history of physics fundamental physics
is that has become increasingly relevant
to let the rest of science precisely one
would argue because of the failure of a
reductionist program so you know as you
can see there are at least two different
reasonable ways of looking at the same
situation throwing very different
conclusions there I really don't think
that either side as a knockdown you're
saying you don't not only don't you do
you not need to invoke the history of
science but you really ought not invoke
the history of science it's simply a
logical argument okay that's a that's an
X n question should the reductase
program actually is a Multi multi do the
progress because there is an issue of
reduction in the sense of you know can I
actually come up with a principled way
to show that that one I think is more
interesting as far as our our discussion
is concerned and am i reading out flows
optical detector is that the majority
philosophers of physics philosopher of
chemistry buzzer biology seems to be
convinced that no that program has not
worked there is no there hasn't nobody
has actually articulated a reasonable
way of
during the reduction other then say
while it's a logically possible
therefore well therefore nothing it
doesn't follow that there are it's
logically possible sure but if you buy
yeah based on what principle well based
on the laws if it's on the principle of
physics it's not enough that the
standard model is incredibly good at the
domain of application when to which it
actually properly applies it says
precisely nothing about any other domain
of again how about what it says about
this thing the all solid state physics
comes from quantum mechanics right and
the technological reliability of them
what we can do with that knowledge is
incomparably greater than it's ever been
and it suggests that higher level
phenomena are fundamentally caused by
lower level phenomena first of all some
suspect is physicists or Flores visit
would actually disagree not on this
particular example but on the
generalization of your of that principle
nobody here is denying that we can use
the deploy fundamental physics to do
stuff even at higher level including
this stuff the claim is not nobody's
claimed that so let's not put up straw
man here the claim is that yes you can
do certain things and then there are
other things for which you need new
principles that you'd have no principled
way to reduce to those fundamental
things that's all right there's the
burden of proof on those who've
succeeded so far or on those who claim
that you want and depends on what you
mean by success if by success you mean
the standard model works in the domain
of application which he does apply yes
but on the other hand that program now
but every week we keep up we keep
increasing the range of application now
there are decoherence and quantum and
quantum locality yes right now it's a
thousand molecules next year it'll be
ten thousand molecules
on the powers microphysics limits but I
think that it's too easy to say well the
burden of proof is on your side
considering that there's been a lot of
theoretical fail production we don't
even we haven't even reduce many
amendments genetics to Molecular
Genetics your get on that subject with
me reductions and failure of us to be
able to use lower levels to prove in a
row but race with that within certain
limits part of me nobody nobody's saying
that using lower level principles we can
make strickland prediction we all agree
my can do matter what so you don't
replace but for the reduction things
yeah yeah there's this the stuff that
we've talked about several times today
about you know using models in physics
presence in space transitions that
actually are used make use of things
like singularities mathematical
singularities not as a problem but as a
feature of those models those those are
very reasonable viable ways of thinking
about emergence they're operational
they're mathematically sound they give
you the information that you want
they don't even broke any spookiness out
there of any kind
they're consistent but they're not
sufficient the new properties they're a
new propresenter
you